un bilan social qui est encore pire
alors oui quand je viens vous dire il ya
un autre projet à mettre en oeuvre il
faut changer les priorités il faut
changer les méthodes il faut changer la
manière dont on envisage
l'économie il faut faire du patriotisme
économique
il faut faire de la relocalisation des
activités
il faut réindustrialiser notre pays il
faut aider les très petites entreprises
et les petites et moyennes entreprises
en leur accordant des baisses de
fiscalité pas aux grands groupes mais
j'ai ma con comme vous l'avez fait car
lorsque vous parlez de baisses d'impôts
vous pensez toujours aux gros et jamais
au petit quand vous parlez des baisses
d'impôts vous avez fait pour les
français vous oubliez de dire que la
plus grosse baisse ça a été évidemment
la suppression de l'info de l'impôt sur
les grandes fortunes
madame le pen a été la baisse de la taxe
d'habitation a été la baisse de la flat
tax et la taxe d'habitation de très très
loin madame le pen la taxe d'habitation
que les français sont en train de payer
dire dans la hausse de prix de la taxe
foncière madame le pen mais les chiffres
que tout le moins et regarder les
chiffres amaechi la cohabitation mais de
très très loin on vous entend débattre
sur le financement de vos programmes ray
mais
madame le pen vous le constaterez en
quelques courtes on n'a absolument pas
répondu sur le co vide j'ai expliqué les
600 milliards de dettes que c'était
c'est la dette que vite ses 600
milliards de dette je les assume
totalement parce que vous savez on a eu
une récession trois fois plus lourde que
pendant la crise financière on en sort
aujourd'hui
comme je le dis dans son programme il
n'ya pas le mot de chômage pourquoi
parce qu'on a et b mais que vous ayez
l'autre quid ans de dire qu'on est des
grands groupes mais que les
restaurateurs que les artisans que les
commerçants que les petits industriels
qui nous écoutent aujourd'hui mais
viennent témoigner vienne vous parler et
vous dire qui les a aidées pendant la
crise qu vide qui les a aidés avec le
fonds de solidarité avec le chômage
partiel avec les prêts garantis avec la
prise en charge parfois de leurs de
leurs propres cotisations c'est le
gouvernement je suis fier qu'on ait fait
ça c'est l'argent de la nation ce 600
milliards de dettes on a constitué tous
ensemble pour protéger ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui madame le pen alors qu'on
a vécu une pandémie comme on en n'avait
pas vécu depuis un siècle on a malgré
tout contrairement aux chiffres que vous
pouvez donner baisser le chômage il est
passé 9 le 6 à 7 4% et le bureau
international du travail comme son nom
l'indiqué elle organise qui fait
référence il vous plaît peut-être pas
mais personne ne compte les catégories b
et c du chômage puisque ce sont des
actifs partiel et seront contents
maintenant qu'on est con pas dans les
chiffres du chômage ne fait pas ils
seront contents de l'ipad gérard majax
ce soir madame le pen a une charge de
l'arrêté arrêter ça ils les chiffres on
parle de vie derrière mais la vie de nos
commerçants de nos artisans c'est ça la
dette qu'ovide vous avez voté contre
expliquez moi quelle centimes c'est la
vie made la députée le pen a voté comme
la députée le pen a voté contre les
votes sont emmanuelle béart est met donc
fait autrement madère le prix que je
vous ai expliqué ce que vous auriez fait
autrement j'aurais fait monde à coups de
secondes madame lopez
va être autrement confinement j'avais
proposé que des fonds propres j'avais
proposé des fonds propres à tous les tpe
pme j'avais proposé 1500 euros par
entreprise plus 1000 euros par salarié
c'était des fonds propres vous avez fait
le choix d'un certain nombre de prêts
des pg e qui aujourd'hui doivent être
remboursés par les entreprises elle n'y
arrivons pas un chat gouffran l'urée ses
boules et écrit beaucoup mourront mail
ou ricanera mais on est des trucs à
l'achat comme et en les décalant
messieurs vous savez ce que vous faites
vous désinscrire et sur les fichiers des
banques quant lui ont fait défaut et
donc ils ne peuvent plus ils ne peuvent
plus investir pour tout le reste
monsieur mâcon vous savez j'étais en
désaccord avec vous après le premier
confinement vous avez continué les
couvre-feux vous avez continué de fermer
les commerces en considérant qu'ils
avaient des essentiels et les non
essentiels eh bien avec tout cela
j'étais en désaccord pour une raison
simple c'est qu'à l'époque à cette
époque là après le premier confinement
on savait qu'en réalité les petits
commerces n'était pas le lieu de
transmission du virus vous avez donc
fait des fermetures administratives et
vous venez expliqué aujourd'hui que les
commerçants devraient vous êtes
reconnaissants de les avoir de leur
avoir compensé les pertes que vous avez
vous même suscité en les fermant de
manière administrative je peux tout à
fait d'accord avec par définissent
marine
[Musique]